جديد ولاية هاتاي بقوة خمس درجات
على مقياس ريختر. افاد المركز
التركي سليمان صويلو يعلن ارتفاع
عدد قتلى زلزال كهرمان مرعش الى
ثلاثة واربعين الفا وخمسمائة
وستة وخمسين شخص بينما ضرب زلزال
الاسرائيلية تدوي مجددا. بينما
دعت مجموعة عرين الاسود الى
القاهرة ومدن اخرى. بوتين يبدأ
عام الحرب بخطوات خطيرة ومرعبة.
البلاء واستعطاف المجتمع الدولي
مضيعة الوقت بحسب بيان للمجموعة.
الحادثة بسرعة. فلديهم معلومات
اكيدة الامريكان بهذا التفجير
الاستعداد للرد على جرائم
الاحتلال. فبيانات الشجب لن تدفع
درجة ريختر ضرب شمال مدينة
السويس شرق مصر وشعر به سكان
حلف بكين وموسكو لا يتوقف وها
هما هنا تبدأن المرحلة الاساسية
المتحدة فدعا الى اجراء تحقيق
موضوعي ومحايد في حادثة انفجار
القصف بالقصف والبادئ اظلم لتطلق
الحركة عددا من الصواريخ نحو
خط انابيب نورد ستريم مشددا على
ضرورة تحديد المسئول عن تلك
المقاومة انها تراقب كل تفاصيل
الاجرام الصهيوني وسترد على
بالقلق من احتمالية دعم بكين
عسكريا لموسكو في الحرب ضد
قال وزير خارجية الكيان
الاسرائيلي كوهين ان هناك اخبارا
جديدة عن انضمام دول عربية
واسلامية لاتفاقيات ابرهم قريبا.
الروسية. ومن الاشتباكات العلنية
الى الحرب السرية من تحت
فما هي الدول التي ستوجه طعنة
غدر للفلسطينيين? وزير الداخلية
المقاتلات الغربية لضرب اهداف
داخل روسيا مؤكدا على ان كييف
الاوروبي المتوسطي لرصد الزلازل
بان زلزالا بقوة اربعة فاصل واحد
القلق وليس العلاقات بين موسكو
وبكين اما مندوب الصين لدى الامم
على القصف الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزة. حركة حماس تحذر من نفاذ صبر
اوكرانيا انه حلف يدعو للقلق حقا
يا هذا. فماذا انت ليأتي الرد من
العالمي والتعاون في اعلى
درجاته، وان العلاقات بين روسيا
الطرفان ان العلاقات بين البلدين
ذات اهمية كبيرة لاستقرار الوضع
تايمز في تحد صارخ من الانجليز
للروس. فهل من رد روسي على ذلك?
بكين وموسكو تتقدمان بثقة
وديناميكية نحو انشاء عالم متعدد
والصين في تطور متزايد وغير
موجهة نحو طرف ثالث. لكن ما يخيف
محذرا من التقارب المتزايد بين
الصين وروسيا. واضاف انه يشعر
الروسية ان قواتها اسقطت طائرة
اوكرانية من طراز سو خمسة وعشرين
بحاجة الى الطائرات لانهاء الحرب
بحسب سكاي نيوز. وهنا نعود الى
النزاع في اوكرانيا فسيؤدي ذلك
الى عواقب جدية. وهنا الامين
الولايات المتحدة وسحب بساطها من
السيطرة العالمية باعلان بوتين
الاقطاب. على الفور خرج الامين
العام لحلف الناتوين ساوتنبرج
وون جي سعي بلديهما لبناء عالم
متعدد الاقطاب. قال وانجي ان
الميدان الاوكراني حيث تدور
المعارك الطاحنة لتعلن الدفاع
في خلسون وقتلت اربعمائة وخمسة
وخمسين جنديا للعدو على اربعة
ويمكن للرئيسين الروسي والامريكي
استخدامه اذا ما رغب بذلك فهل
البريطانية شكلت فرقة عمل سرية
مهمتها الحصول على ذخيرة حربية
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني التصدي
لنحو تسعين هجوما للقوات
عن غضبه قائلا ان اذا لم يتم
الاستماع الى موقف الصين بشأن
محاور قتال اساسية في دومباز
خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة بينما
مجموعة من الشرطة الوطنية الى
كييف تضمنت مهمتها تنفيذ عملية
المستوطنات الاسرائيلية المحاذية
للقطاع وصفارات الانذار
بريطانيا ايضا تجري حربها عن بعد
مع الدب الروسي. فوزارة الدفاع
سوفيتية لتغطية حاجة القوات
الاوكرانية وفق صحيفة نيويورك
استمرار دعم اوكرانيا حتى تنتصر
وفق قوله. وبين هذا وذاك عاد
التي تحتضن المناورات بخليج
بيتشرد. الاحداث والتطورات. ردا
لمناورات بحرية مشتركة وليس
لوحدهما بل مع دولة جنوب افريقيا
الدور الصيني مع خصوم واشنطن.
وهنا يلتقي الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين مع كبير
الدبلوماسي الصينيين وانجي ليؤكد
تطهير بعض الاراضي من الالغام
بحسب صحيفة فكيف سترد موسكو.
الصين تعلن عن تحالفها. حلف صيني
روسي قوي. وقلق امريكي جديد من
الى بدايتها. فهل يجد اصحاب
العيون الضيقة حلا وسط لجميع
الخارجية الصيني ان دور واشنطن
المدمرة في العالم هو ما يثير
الطاولة. نفذت بولندا عملية
امنية سرية في اوكرانيا بارسالها
الجيوسياسي الحالي ليظهر نائب
رئيس البرلمان الاوكراني مصرحا
الذكرى الاولى للحرب زين مسكي
بتحقيق النصر. ليقول لم ننكسر.
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بخطوات
تصعيدية. حيث قال ان الجيش وضامن
تطالب الغرب مرارا وتكرارا
بالطائرات. هنا وزير الخارجية
الرئيس الامريكي لم يجرؤ على
التوجه الى كييف دون اخطار روسيا
او مطالبة الجانب الروسي بمراعاة
شروط سلامته. اما كييف فلا زالت
وصفه بالاعتداءات الروسية على
امن اوروبا. مضيفا انه يجب
الاوكراني ديمترو كوليفا يشدد
على ان بلاده لن تستخدم
هناك دعا الاتحاد الاوروبي موسكو
الى السماح بتفتيش مخزونها
اذا ارادت الولايات المتحدة
وهزيمتهم. لكن العام الجديد
للحرب لن يكون كسابقه فها هو
يبدأ بتعليق روسيا معاهدة ليرد
على ليلاه. ليظهر نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف
والقاسية. المتحدثة الروسية
ماريا زاخاروفا والتي قالت ان
فرانس بريس. ليعود المسؤول
الاوكراني محذرا من ان اي خطة
سلام يجب الا تتجاوز الخطوط
الحمراء التي وضعتها كييب. فيما
حان وقت التفاوضية هؤلاء لننتقل
الى صاحبة الردود اللاذعة
طاولة السلام. حيث اكد مسؤول
اوكراني رفيع المستوى ان الحكومة
بانهم يرحبون بخطة الصين للسلام
لكن بشروط زيلانسكي لتعود العجلة
الذي يجري والرئيس البلاروسي?
استمعوا لموقف الصين من حرب
قاربها مع خطة لعالم جديد. فهل
ينجح اصحاب العيون الضيقة? زلزال
العام لحلف الناتو ينس تلتومبيرج
لم يقف ساكتا. وتوعد بوضع حد لما
المتحدث الروسي بيسكوف ان خط
الاتصالات الساخن بالطبع موجود
الاطراف هناك عبر رئيس
البلاروسية الكسندر لوكا شينكو
قالت الروسية ان التسوية مرهونة
باعتراف كييف والغرب بالواقع
اوكرانيا التي من المفترض
اعلانها هذا الاسبوع بحسب وكالة
ينوي بوتين حسم امر الاقاليم
الاربعة قريبا? ارض المعارك الى
الصينية لم تتشاور مع كييف اثناء
اعداد خطتها المقترحة للسلام في
تصعيدية عسكرية خطيرة. والزينسكي
تخطينا الكثير من المحن وسوف
تقول ان القوات الروسية تستعد
لهجوم واسع جنوب دونيتسك. فهل
العالم? الجواب يأتي من
الاستخبارات البريطانية. والتي
والهدف هو الاستجابة لحاجات
القوات في وقال بوتين ان بلاده
تخطينا الكثير من المحن وسوف
ننتصر. سوف نحاسب جميع الذين
جلبوا هذا الشر وهذه الحرب الى
ارضنا. ليأتي الرد من الرئيس
الثالوث النووي. فلماذا كل هذه
الاستعدادات? هل اقتربت نهاية
ستولي اهتماما متزايدا لتعزيز
قواتها النووية ورفع جاهزية
والصين تواصل وساطتها فايهما يصل
هدف واولا وساطة بكين ام
على لسان متحدث الكرملين ديمتري
بيسكوف الذي قال ان روسيا ستتحلى
بالصبر في انتظار ان ينضج الغرب
لاجراء حوار طبيعي حول ستارت.
بوضع شرط واحد للعودة الى معاهدة
نيو ستارت النووية مع امريكا.
مشاركة روسيا في معاهدة نيو
ستارت اخر معاهدة متبقية بين
قائلا انه اذا اوقفت روسيا الحرب
سيتم تمزيقها الى اشلاء. مضيفا
النووي بموجب معاهدة نيو ستارت
ها فعن اي يتحدثون لتستجيب روسيا
وذلك لمراعاة مخاوف موسكو
المشروعة بحسب تعبيره. وعشية
الرئيس الامريكي ان نظيره الروسي
ارتكب خطأ فادحا باعلانه تعليق
موسكو وواشنطن تضع قيودا على
اسلحتهما النووية الاستراتيجية.
استقرار الدولة الروسية واعدا
بزيادة انتاج الصناعات العسكرية
انه اذا الولايات المتحدة امداد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحة فستنتهي الحرب
السلاح النووي للدفاع عن النفس
وانهم سيحاربون بكل سلاح يمتلكون
الان. هناك اعلنها ميدفيديف
صراحة انه يحق لبلاده اللجوء الى
العين بالعين والبادئ اظلم.
العام الروسي الجديد ليس
اوكرانيا والا فلا تدوم الا
انفسكم. بكين تضم موسكو الى
جديد يضرب مصر وعرين والمقاومة
الفلسطينية ترد على الاحتلال.
كالماضي. عام على الحرب بالتمام
والكمال وكل ادلى بدلوه وكل يغني
في اوكرانيا والخط الساخن يعود
من جديد بين امريكا وروسيا. فما
لمعاهدة ستورت وبايدن يرد. دولة
اوروبية تنفذ عملية امنية سرية
ننتصر. الناتو يتوعد الروس
وموسكو تضع شروطها للعودة
روسيا وبعد تعليق المعاهدة
النووية. بوتين يأمر بخطوات
سنفتح مخازن اسلحتنا وسنقاتلكم
بكل سلاح نمتلكه. هكذا اعلنتا